I was dying and I realized,
all right,
you know,
I need to keep working.
What am I gonna do?
I went back and revisited some of these songs,
but I realize I have to rerecord them.
That's why I didn't see that they were my songs because I recorded into my way
that I thought other people would want to use them.
So I went and recorded about,
I dunno,
five or six of the songs that were already here.
And then my buddy evidence from dilated peoples,
um,
got involved with me and we recorded a few of these rap tracks and it started
kind of coming together and it kind of started coming together in a similar way
that the original Whitey force things to blues record did.
That's why I kind of also named it what it is.
Um,
there was a lot of similarities and I feel like I just pulled everything from
every part of the toolbox that I've learned from since I started.
You know what it was the ice tea years are the house of pain years or the Whitey
Ford years.
I just drew on it all and trying to see what you're,
like I said it was in the eight years of life,
it's not like a literal representation of what's happened to me,
but it's an emotional journey of like all the kinds of feelings and shit that,
a lot of struggles and a lot of it's,
it's,
it's my best record,
you know,
but eight years right here.
So I've never been in a rush.
That's a big statement that it's your best wreck.
It's my best record ever.
I'm,
I'm confident in it.
Is it available everywhere?
Like on a file stream,
the shit out of it.
I own my masters.
I mean how does that work?
If you own your masters,
do you get more stream?
Well,
if you own your masters,
you get paid outright.
Like,
you know,
you're the label on my own label.
So that people that complain about not getting paid by streaming or people that
are signed to record deals that are getting a small piece of what the masters
getting.
Uh,
if you own the master,
you know,
you still streaming is viable for someone who owns the master.
I mean as viable period.
I mean kids,
I mean that's the way it is.
It's just the,
it's the future.
But the people who say it doesn't pay their in shitty deals,
you know what I mean?
Cause it,
it pays.
No,
I would like it to pay a little better,
but you know,
it pays.
It pays all right.
Who Was it?
I think if you take a million streams it equals out to around $8,000.
That sounds like it just in general,
like that's the payment for it,
for what that is to have to a label,
like it would be around a label,
like a million streams is,
is about the equipment,
about eight grant.
And uh,
that doesn't sound like a lot,
but a million streams is like,
you know,
a thousand guys that,
or people,
fans of yours that stream your shit,
whatever,
a thousand times,
a hundred times.
Right.
You know,
it's not,
it goes quicker than you think.
I think Drake like streamed a billion streams as first week.
Right.
You know,
that's a nice chunk of change,
man.
David Crosby was tweeting about how bad streaming deals are,
but that is because he has a bad deal as he doesn't own his master.
Yeah.
If he does,
if he's like recording a deal for another record for the record company,
you know what I mean?
Then he's all his older songs.
Oh,
that's,
yeah.
Then he's probably got shit deals and I mean,
some of my older stuff,
I don't get paid on what I feel like I should,
but it's like the stuff,
since I've owned my masters,
which is the last 15 years of my life,
you know what I mean?
It's fascinating from me on the outside looking at what happens with labels and
how the,
how they do things.
It's,
it's just,
it's amazing.
They're sort of survival instincts.
Have they figured out how to stay in Naples or signing podcasters now because of
streaming,
streaming tech?
You should be getting checks from this,
Joe.
I don't,
I don't allow them to stream me,
but would honestly,
you could be coming Dora Spotify,
I say,
nope.
Well,
you'd probably have to be exclusive to one of them is the deal too.
Um,
well either way what they are is just,
it's not just streaming.
Your Youtube views are streaming.
That's streaming doesn't have to be with a streaming service.
Right.
I mean,
but you,
you should have a digital company that is representing you,
that's collecting all that.
If you don't yeah,
no,
I do for that and just make sure.
Yeah,
but that's like that's all streaming.
It's,
you know what the youtube thing,
the most fascinating thing about it is that there's only youtube.
That's the crazy thing.
We think about how big the Internet is and there's really only one thing like
youtube,
it's a,
it was a good moment.
They came and the branding and everything they did,
I saw like,
I don't know if it was a documentary because it wasn't full length,
but it might've been just like a little like feature like it within a news kind
of segment thing about how,
you know,
the original videos that were huge on on youtube where like a kid biting another
kid and like their original first for the longest time,
the most played video on youtube was the Charlie biting the kid or something.
You know?
And that's where it all came from.
Like it almost came from America's home video of funniest home video kind of
thing.
Youtube kind of filled in that void for a long time.
They were memes before there were memes,
they were just viral videos,
you know,
so long ago.
That's crazy.
It's like a decade ago.
And that,
well,
I mean the necessity of having to change the music business is what changed
youtube,
you know,
because they caught on like our itvs and I was in play videos anymore and
nobody's buying records.
So we got to,
so you know,
the whole,
the whole thing for the longest was like when the bottom had really fallen out
for a while of making any money off of actual records was like,
well you can bootleg my record and you can download my record,
but you can't download the tee shirt.
I,
so it became sell the lifestyle.
So the music became background music to the,
you know,
everything else.
It was a part of the lifestyle and the cars and this and all I wanted you to do
is really go by this limited edition tee shirt that I'm sending you right now.
You know what I mean?
That's what that's the game changed into and it's still that,
you know what I mean?
That's why the fuck are we in the troll Islam and all that.
Because people want eyes on them.
So the next thing they have the opportunity to sell,
they can sell.
Yeah.
That's what's interesting to me about labels is now labels get a piece of
everything.
They do these three 60 deals,
that's Satan correct scene.
That was unheard of.
You didn't get pieces,
not only t shirts,
there's,
you get pieces of it,
they get a piece of live money.
You get every,
you know,
and it's like how it used to be like I had to pay you.
I used to be like,
all right,
a record label would give me half a million dollars.
All right.
And I'd go and make a record with that.
I'd have,
I could spend whatever I want to make an a record and whatever the rest of money
left over was mine.
That 500 grand was mine.
I can spend it all making a record or I can spend 50 grand making a record and
pocket the rest.
That was up to me.
Um,
and then after that,
my GI,
your job was a label is to sell that record.
My job was to hit the road and go tour and I go to her for a few years and at
first I'm not even making money to her.
And you're giving me money to go out there and sore.
It's called tour support.
That used to be,
and that actually gets added onto your bill paid?
No.
You would get like money for tour,
but like it wouldn't cover like a bus and a band and all this so that the label
would supplement that with what they called tour support,
which would also become part of the debt.
You owe the label,
but as you build your live audience,
your guarantees would go up sooner or later.
You could stop taking that money and then your record sales would pay that off
hopefully.
If you were doing well enough and now you got your own stream of revenue with
live t shirts,
all this other outside shit that it's yours.
That's the way it was when I came up.
Now it's like that's not a deal.
They want it all out.
How'd they sneak that in?
Because when Napster and should drop the bottom out of the record business,
nobody was paying for records.
Labels weren't gonna give you a half a million dollars just for your record
because nobody was buying records.
They want to sell your tee shirts too.
It's that amazing note.
They figured out how to stay alive like that just because they always knew that
people are going to be needy.
It always it.
It all boils down to this too and I host somebody one day like really
investigates this and make some sort of like documentary about it is like they
had so many opportunities to be ahead of the movie industry didn't take the same
hit.
They took hits and they deal dealt with piracy,
but they,
the music industry had a moment.
If you remember,
there was like some kids they got in trouble for downloading ridiculous amounts
of music and their parents were being held responsible and the music industry
backed off of it because the news wasn't good.
The movie industry never backed off of that kind of shit.
They've told you we're going to fucking sue your life off.
People did get sued for your music,
but the music industry backed off though.
They didn't put the pedal down and keep the foot on the neck like you're going
to steal this,
this costs.
You got to remember back then,
if I would've got a half a million dollars,
I probably would have spent up to,
to have that on a record,
$200,000 just on them making studio time.
Whoever's got to be involved in engineers,
producers,
200 grand off top,
just that's minimum we would have spent on a record.
And then it gets,
you go out and people steal it.
Right.
You know what mean it's the same,
you know?
Did you ever download shit for free?
Um,
my thing we not at first my thing became later like,
okay,
this is what they,
this is the wave,
whatever.
But if I doubt my,
my philosophy was if I downloaded your shit and I liked it,
I would go,
I'd go buy it.
Like I,
if I,
if I download it and it was trashed and bay,
I looked at it as like a taste test.
That's okay.
Okay.
Maybe if more people adapted that things would it.
But again,
the record industry had plenty of opportunities to jump ahead of it.
And B,
they didn't,
there was technology out there already that people were dealing with.
Sound bringing it so that I'm telling him and this wave is coming.
So when the record industry was making so much money at that time,
if you look at the amount of money they were making off of the boy bands and the
Brittany Spears,
is it not that it was retarded how much money was in the record business and
they let it all go down the drain because they thought they had all the answers
and they thought it had it.
No one money.
What could they have done to stop it?
I'd have to go,
I have some books on it.
It sounds like there was taking out a lot hole for string equal.
There were people ready there to help set up things like nasty and how to
monetize it and control it.
Like there was ways to deal with it.
There were ways to be part of it instead of like wait until it was too late.
Well,
think about the movie industry too though,
is that people want to go to the movies.
Like the experience is not as good.
Apple music saved the music industry like apple at first.
Itunes.
Why didn't the record history like there were people telling them this is coming
and I didn't mean to interrupt you,
but it don't think they could've made iTunes first,
not called iTunes,
but like it's security industry itself should have had digitized and been ready.
It would have been asked simple come up with their own version of iTunes and
they could have invested a lot more money to music industry is booming,
but artists are losing big because most artists are signed to record deals with
just 12% of revenue.
12% whoa.
$43 billion a year was its most profitable year since 2006 Yup.
Listeners to spending more money than ever,
largely on streaming and live music with consumer spinning tow totaling more
than $20 billion last year.
Wow.
Yet artists aren't feeling the increase of that 20 billion music industry
entities such as record labels took home 10 billion musicians taking home just
5.1 billion with the majority of their revenue coming from touring and concert
sales.
It's amazing.
That's amazing that it's like a parasitic industry.
It's like you,
they don't,
people don't necessarily need them the way they used to it.
Nina.
Not they'd like they used to.
I was going to just play devil's advocate and say,
well,
it used to be that I'm the guy to put up all the,
if I'm the label,
Oh,
I'm putting up millions of dollars in advance.
Gambling it on you right now.
When you,
when you want to take away my blind,
share it.
No.
Fuck you.
Now it's totally different.
Now you can do this on your own.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You could start an Instagram started youtube,
start this,
and you can make beats on your laptop and like living wrapper.
Right?
Isn't that the guy who does everything?
Everything he's done is his own shit online.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Yeah.
You don't believe it.
What do you mean?
Oh,
Jamie's got a conspiracy theory conspiracy,
but he's got more support than he would say now he does.
Sure.
Yeah.
No,
it does.
Maybe,
but I mean,
basically he's become huge all on his own.
Right.
And you didn't meet me.
You look,
it's like so many viral music hits.
You know they get,
they get big online just because kids share it and they like it then then it
becomes gigantic.
Like what the music industry that the industry,
the labels have nothing to do with that,
right?
No they,
there's labels that are doing their thing after that.
They actually know what they're doing and marketing wise and all that.
And there's still a lot of kids that are being made famous by label.
So there's some benefit.
I mean there's a lot,
at least not a lot of the reasons.
Some of these artists are only seeing 5.1 minutes cause they're signed to record
deals.
You know,
Jay z ain't only seen five,
you know,
5% of what you he's do cause he,
he's been in the game long enough.
He know and they started out with their own label.
They started to bend the beginning.
Rockefeller records was independent.
So that's the kind of,
you know,
those guys and guys are never going to lose as long as you know,
they can still make music that people buy.
Yeah.
They figure out a way to rope you in early to where like even if your record is
successful,
the second record you,
it's not like you're going to be able to be independent in the second record.
They'll you,
they own you for several down the line.
Right.
Usually,
I mean it used to be,
I think the standard was like eight eight yeah,
it's that.
But that's it.
That's,
it's,
it's misleading because it depends on where you're from too.
There's also like,
you know,
if your first record is very successful and you have a lawyer that has anywhere
with all you're renegotiating before you do a second record,
you know what I mean?
These are things you learn,
but like if you're struggling at eight record thing too.
Also,
if you study the record business,
it goes back to like when actually artists used to be built that like over w
nobody expected the first album to do anything.
Like when they would sign bands like in the 60s the bike,
but you know,
they had a plan like my album three and four here's where we'll be.
You know,
they used to build artists.
They used to be a and are they actually used to nurture and fucking take care of
a band for a long time and watched them grow.
What I mean that's the way it used to be until like,
you know,
whatever it was maybe the 80s it changed.
I had a record deal for my comedy album in 1999 I had a record deal with Warner
brothers.
It was like a real record deal,
like good met with them.
They promoted it,
the look,
the whole deal.
It was like I went through the whole record industry business.
There was always a comedian or two on labels.
I don't have that anymore because Tom many albums,
they're do it yourself.
Well,
it's not just that you definitely can do it yourself,
but comedy albums just aren't that popular anymore for some strange reason.
Well,
because it's,
it's,
it's a piss poor.
It's also the art form you want to watch it exactly was about to say it's so,
it's so visual that now comedy albums were big when everybody didn't have a TV
screen or everything.
He was like,
you could listen and imagine what we,
what he was doing or saying.